[music]
>> We'll take just one or two because Kelly
must to come for the next session.
Okay, brother Ibrahim. As-salamu
alaykum.
Wa alaykumu s-salam wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. I'm not 100% sure if it's
related to the subject, but I can't see
it on the schedule.
What is the
ruling on giving dawah
to a non-mahram
if the opportunity arises? For example,
if they say something belittling to your
religion,
what should your correspondence be in
that situation? Brother Ibrahim, that's
a very good question, that what is the
ruling on doing dawah to non-mahram,
talking about opposite sex, when the
opportunity arises? See, while doing
dawah to a non-mahram, or while doing
dawah to anyone, see to it that you do
not break any rules of the Sharia.
So, if you know your Sharia well, you
cannot say for dawah, I can break the
rule.
Everyone has his hijab. And I've been to
many Muslim countries, I don't want to
name it.
Big dawah center, biggest in the
country.
Phenomenal work.
There I find a lady
doing dawah to a non-Muslim man in a
closed room.
What is this?
I'm doing dawah for the sake of Allah.
Our beloved Prophet Muhammad s.a.w.s.
said that if a man and a woman,
non-mahram, are together in one room,
the third person is the Shaitan, is the
devil.
There is no exception. You can't say I'm
a da'ee, I can break. You cannot break a
single rule. You cannot do a single
haram. You can do a thing which is
makruh, no problem.
Like standing and drinking water is
makruh, it is not haram. So, if I stand
and drink water, it's acceptable, though
I don't I used to do that earlier. I
stopped that.
Only on the stage that's allowed, I have
knowledge. But most of the Muslims DON'T
KNOW. OH, ZAKIR, HARAM, DRINKING WATER
ON THE STAGE. THEY never used to listen
to me.
I said, because of the lack of
knowledge, I said, "Okay, my dawah
lesson then I drink.
Let a small loss take place to prevent a
big loss."
Many people say wearing a tie haram. And
they do not knowledge of the deen.
Anyway, so coming to your question, that
while doing dawah, if it's a non-mahram.
Point number one, if you're doing dawah
to a non-mahram, see to it that the
mahram of that girl is there. Maybe the
husband, maybe the brother, or maybe
there's another girl with her, so that
it breaks the thing of only one-to-one.
If you're forced to do in one-to-one,
don't do in closed room.
Do it
in a public area. But when you're
speaking,
you have to
not follow certain techniques of public
speaking. No, why? Anything, any
technique, any expert which tells you
something against Quran and Sunnah,
forget it. Quran and Sunnah are number
one, we'll deal with that later on. The
question comes in that, but because you
asked, I mentioned.
There's eye-to-eye contact. When you
speak, eye-to-eye contact, the impact is
better. It's public speaking skills. I
can talk with my eyes.
With my mouth I talk separately, with my
eyes I'm talking separately. But here,
you don't look, you lower your gaze.
If you don't look, 5% less effective. No
problem.
Allah and his Rasul
are a million times more important than
any technique.
So, here, when you're speaking to a man,
you can have that gesture, EYE-TO-EYE
CONTACT, TALK, no problem. Lady,
you have to lower your gaze.
So, if
you are in a closed area, if a mahram is
there, or a friend is there, you're
talking with lowering your gaze, no
problem. If a situation arises where
you're somewhere outside in a public
area,
then no problem, but see to it that you
lower your gaze.
I know
in the Western world, when you talk and
you don't look at the person, it is an
insult. I'm aware of it.
So, when I'm talking to someone for a
very long time, and I realize that she's
feeling insulted, you say, "Sorry,
sister, actually this is in our religion
that we aren't allowed to stare at a
non-mahram." And this is even in
Christianity. It's even in your Bible.
Really?
Yes, it's mentioned in the Bible, in the
Gospel of Matthew, chapter number five,
verse number 27 and 28, that if anyone
looketh at a woman to lust after her,
has already committed adultery in the
heart.
So, now I'm using my
comparative religion
and telling her and making her not feel
bad.
But when I'm making her not feel bad,
I'm not breaking any rules of my Sharia.
It's a common practice.
When you go in Western world, they shake
your hand. And unfortunately, most of
the Muslims would then forward.
Some like it or not, no problem. Some
even if they don't like it,
they are forced to do it because
they are caught unaware.
So, you as a da'ee, if you are trained,
when a lady puts her hand forward, how
to react. If you're not trained, your
reaction would be even though you know
it's haram, your hand will go forward. I
don't want to take the head count here.
You'll be shocked to know, if I take the
head count here, more than 50% would be
shaking hands with ladies.
Maybe good.
What do you say? How can I
Oh, she'll feel hurt. It's haram in
Islam to hurt anyone's feeling. Haram,
but that doesn't mean you do haram to
make her not do haram.
So, unless your mind is trained, what
will I do? And I travel
a lot.
And I meet up people.
Just an example, I was there last year,
one year three months back, I was in
Gambia. And the President of Gambia
invited me. And he honored me. And the
best honor I ever got
from any head of state in the world,
it's from Gambia. When I got the
invitation, I did not know Gambia
existed. I said, "I know Zambia, what is
Gambia?" So, I saw on the map, it's on
the west coast of Africa, just inside
Senegal. I said, "Who called President?"
I checked up on my President, he's
there. Okay, fine. Good dawah.
And when I landed there,
the foreign minister came to Senegal to
pick me up.
When I landed there, the cabinet was
waiting at the airport.
I had a crew of mashallah 50 people with
me
to do the shooting. When we go out, we
find thousands OF PEOPLE FOR MILES
TOGETHER, KILOMETERS. I said, "What is
this?"
I learned this and that. I said,
"Gambia, I don't know where it existed."
I'm coming out of the airport, thousands
of people waiting in a queue.
What is this?
Then they tell me, "Oh, Peace TV is
popular here."
Thousands of people for kilometers, you
know, we have
some religious leaders, when they come
at airport, they have kilometers, I
don't want to take the name, kilometers.
I said, "What is this?"
Alhamdulillah, Allah gives the izzah.
But the point to be noted that he made
me the chief guest
for his
national day.
And I was on the stage,
and he was there, and all the
ambassadors of different countries were
there, and I congratulated him, and then
after the speech, everyone came to
congratulate him. So, I was there first,
so first they shook hands with me,
as the protocol, then they went to him.
No problem. Suddenly, I find ladies
coming.
I said, "Sorry, sister, I cannot shake
hand."
The President saw me.
Immediately, he told the foreign
minister, "Stand next to Dr. Zakir."
And the foreign minister said, "Sorry,
ma'am, can you go ahead?" I maintained
my hijab.
I did not shake hand.
But imagine, the President, you're the
chief guest, and the President is
calling you, and you don't shake hand
with the ambassador of USA.
Let her feel bad. I cannot jeopardize my
akhirah.
Now, you unless you're trained, you may
be a good Muslim, you may know it is
wrong, but President has called me, and
the ambassador of USA coming to meet me.
Or of a European country, I don't know
which country or But the good part to be
noted is
I liked the attitude of the President.
Fine, he was shaking hand, good Muslim,
but may not follow
everything. Good Muslim, alhamdulillah.
But he took care of his guest.
Otherwise, unlike,
"Oh, you offended me."
And in the national anthem, there was
some music being played. He realized I
was uncomfortable. So, he said, "Ask Dr.
Zakir that if he's uncomfortable, he can
leave." So, I told him, "If the
President
will not feel offended, I'd like to
leave." And believe me, I left the
program.
It was good of him
to give me permission,
not knowing that it's a program where in
the anthem there is an orchestra.
So, I liked his attitude. Alhamdulillah,
unlike the other presidents.
After I left, a lot, mashallah.
So, here, irrespective of who you meet,
irrespective if you're trained,
otherwise a normal person who's a good
da'ee also, 99% will shake hands. Unless
you're trained not to shake hands.
Because refusing a hand of a woman,
difficult.
Correct?
Right or wrong?
Right or wrong, Aisha?
Refusing a hand of woman is difficult or
not?
Easy for you, I know. You're from
America.
Huh? No, no, before it was difficult,
now it's getting easier.
>> No, now because I'm here for the last
seven How many years? Seven years. Seven
years. Now, you cannot shake hand, huh?
Halal, Zakir will
>> Yeah, it doesn't happen.
>> Zakir will sack you. I don't really care
much anyway. I don't care also.
You have an American who stayed for many
years.
Masha Allah. In America, it's a natural
reaction. So, unless you're trained, so
while doing Dawah to even a non-Mahram,
it is preferable one-to-one. Man does to
a man, woman does to a man. We are doing
public Dawah and women are there, no
problem. It's indirect. One-to-one in
IRF, no lady can come and meet me
personally.
It's not allowed in our organization. If
she has to come, I said go to a ladies'
wing. We have a specialist ladies. My
wife is there, we have ladies, they will
do. And yet if they want a super
specialist and if they think I'm the
only one who can solve, yes, then I say,
"Okay, come with your husband." And I
see to it many a time my wife is there.
And I know many examples. One lady was
there, she liked my lecture and she
accepted Islam through my lecture. She
said, "Convince my husband." And she was
an MBA and the husband was MBA. And I
remember that after Isha, I gave her the
time knowing that it will take about 1
hour 2 hours that day. I'm talking about
many years back. And so I called my wife
and after Isha, we started. So, he said,
"I have got 10 questions on Islam." I
said, "Khalas." So, I said, "If I answer
this 10, will you say the Shahada?" He
said, "Yes." And we started. Blah blah.
Before Fajr salah, alhamdulillah, he
said the Shahada.
Now, that thing we don't have the time,
we don't have
spending 6 hours with one person is
difficult.
So, my wife was there after
Isha with me and that lady
and her husband.
While talking, though the wife is asking
the question, I'm looking at the husband
and talking. This is another way.
You can't look at the lady, look at the
husband. Or look at the brother. Or if
only lady is there, then lower your
gaze. Or if your wife is there, as your
Mahram, you can look at her wife and
talk. So, it requires training. To say
is easy,
but unless you not trained, it's
difficult. So, while doing Dawah, don't
break any rules of the Quran and the
sahih hadith. Any technique in the
world, any specialist in the world
cannot overrule Allah and his Rasul.
Even what I say,
if unintentionally or BY MISTAKE, I SAY
ANYTHING which goes against Quran or any
of the sahih hadith, reject Dr. Zakir
Naik. Dr. Zakir Naik in Islam is zero.
Allah
and his Rasul,
they are number one.
Even if I'm logical, even if I'm
scientific, anything, if it clashes
with Allah and his Rasul, they are
superior.
I don't intend telling anything against
the Quran and hadith, but
unintentionally or by mistake, out of
ignorance, even if I say something
against Quran and Sunnah, I always tell
all my audience, all my students, all my
colleagues, all my workers, if I say
something unintentionally,
intentionally, inshallah, I'll never say
anything against Quran and Sunnah,
reject my saying.
However appealing it may be to you.
Because Allah and his Rasul,
they are superior than everyone in this
world.
So, while doing Dawah, see to it that
you don't break any rules of the Quran
and Sharia. In detail, we'll discuss
when we do the structure and technique.
I feel now we'll end the session. We are
already late and I request that brother
Kaleem, you are supposed to give a talk
on characteristics of a Daii. And the
next session I kept for 2 hours
purposely to adjust. I think 3 minutes
each multiplied by
20 students, 1 hour plus walking would
take approximately 1 hour 15 minutes if
you do it in time. So, we will have the
session
of brother Kaleem
for the first
inshallah, 45 minutes.
His session on characteristics of a Daii
followed by question answer session. And
then we'll have the 3 minutes speech of
the participants so that we will catch
up on the time we have spent on the
other things like material for the
knowledge of Islam.
I love question answer session. And I
always prefer question answer session to
be longer, but I have a great problem in
training programs. In lectures, I see to
it that if I give 1 hour lecture, the
question answer session is 2 to 3 hours.
Here, I would love it.
And I feel very bad if I end the session
without answering questions, but
we are already late. We are late by
about 12 minutes. Plus
brother Kaleem's session, so behind
schedule by about 50 minutes. Not that
we wasted time. We started 7 minutes
before. It is because the questions came
from you and we have to reply. Or I gave
more time to material for knowledge
while scratching the dust
on the surface.
Inshallah, we will assemble here
inshallah as per the time schedule. We
will not delay. We will assemble at
2:15. We are ending about 11 12 minutes
late. You read the salah inshallah, have
your lunch, and we'll assemble at 2:15
sharp inshallah for the session of
brother Kaleem on characteristics of a
Daii followed by question answer
session, followed by 3 minutes prepared
speech of the participants. Wa akhir
al-da'wa alhamdulillah rabbil alamin.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.